So. Tweet yes. You know it. Just. Hello. I am. Terry mcgee and.
I mean this name and story because i was a participant at the original. Aquarius festival. Who stayed on and.
I came a few weeks before the festival. A friend of mine bob craven.
And and others here working as part of the organization. And i came up did a bit of help in the architectural.
Team before hand. And then this here for the festival. I suppose. The.
My further relevance why i'm still sort of talking about it is because at the end of the festival.
There was one workshop. Being chaired by richard neville. To discuss. Lyta. Communities being formed in the area.
After the festival and. I was at the workshop. We talked for hours. Richard never invited one particular person.
To organize some sort of. After the festival. Process and.
I guess i had a feeling that that particular person was not going to be incredibly successful in doing it.
And i simply set about with some discussion. With kenya emmons the son of the irrigation.
I set about starting a tunnel force. Registering the cooperative. Arranging the deal on the land and then.
Going through the process of trying to build up an organization that the cooperative
when it was registered would be the legal part of it you hadn't come with an intention to stay i came up with the
possibility i mean i didn't know i had i don't know why is thought about moving up to the north coast of new south
wales. But i expected that. Any place that i would want to would be right on the coast.
And so i hadn't expected to come up with to decide to do that so that was a challenge of my story writer.
In one of the stories that. I was writing in. And still haven't finished at that. At that time was the story of. I.
And i lodge island where people were coming in from overseas. Almost in their dreams. To build new communities.
To get away from various. All world problems. And so i just sort of automatic lee.
Thought to myself of this was part of the. Graham.
Ending of making that story a very real very detail being up to help on details of that story. I also thought that.
Because of the festival. And some of the people that were here. That there was the spirit. In terms of.
An artistic community. One that was interested in a lot of. A lot of thoughts a lot of new ideas and.
That this might in fact be a better. Such place than one on the coast. That would get distracted by the.
The joys of the beach. It was more the color. The background.
It was almost like a movie that was a great movie but they forgot to put in part of the story.
There was no connecting story. And i felt that. At the time. I felt that part of that reason was that.
Because it had been centered on the town. Instead of. It. One of the other options before the festival.
Was to try to arrange hannibal falls. The whole property as the festival site.
And if that would have been the case then the festival. Would have.
They would have been a story of the building of a new town. The creating the starting of a new town village.
But because it was. Trains a tree in that sense of. The coming and going. It was almost. Describe the best way that i.
I thought of late it was to talk.
I had images of some songs and story of a guy was walking along the street of nim been. After the festival.
And that he was.
This little country town that had been so incredibly alive like a like thirty or forty thousand people really.
Because all of it. Not that there were that many people but.
All of its residents were very active they were going out and so you had this. Be artistic town.
And then it was totally empty and. It was full of ghosts. Well it's sort of like the story that guys tell is.
That's hard to actually capture on film. Because when you shoot it. You can't see the guys.
And you can hear what they sign. But you see the color. I guess. The guys.
But that they haven't made themselves particularly. More visible. They are they. I don't think that.
It's the town itself has moved a huge distance from its potential. Its potential is.
Are something where there is an artistic economic life. That requires a town.
There's not that level of of really solid artistic business. That is being done. To justify its existence as.
It's exists. And says the townies.
Is a story call that there was a town there that was empty and was not being used very much. Because all of its.
Not all but one half of its residents were pensioners and so they were just enjoying this beautiful little tan
but it wasn't. It wasn't doing much. It wasn't very alive it wasn't doing a lot of business and.
The things that could have occurred during the festival. Or straight after the festival.
Didn't occur and haven't occurred yet. Even with all this business activity.
You know new shops at ning in town at the moment that i. And they.
They're not touching anything like the potential for a true arts center. Alternative out center.
Alternative arts capital of astride whatever. You can go. And choose lots of.
Sort of ways to describe most likely at the moment byron bay is more of an art center and. In this mall than.
The name and. Anyway. I think it's more the. The whole way cannot make the whole way konami. Superstructure the whole.
Sense of taking. Taking taking the business side of it all seriously. I guess it's.
In many ways you get the feeling of people running around making a movie but the movie never gets made. Well.
The other. Classic example is the town of all fours whole. It's been under constricts a beautiful structure.
And it's a really beautiful. Really elegant.
Really nicely designed but it's been under construction for sixteen years now. Something like sixteen years. Where.
As i say bill and cliffs. There's been quite a beautiful. New crafts. Build. In three months.
And it's completed its opening next weekend. And that sort of frustration. At this beautiful hole.
That is is quite stunning in is the sort of classic game gradients. For a very artistic. But business. Real.
Artistic as in. That makes money. Is this whole that would be beautiful.
Part of that is incomplete after fifteen years. It's going the way. I think it's. The different parts of life.
That the communities being able to face up to one. Two whole aspects very very well brilliantly.
But haven't gone beyond those and i organized why. If you look at. The whole. If you look at the.
The development of a community from scratch. Such as at a tunnel before us. And really you can treat the whole of the.
Newman valley in that way because the number of people in houses and other things for people to do other than.
Milk cows. The level of that. In this valley twenty years ago was a fairly low level. There wasn't a huge amount of.
Of this. Develop space. And ton of all. When it started. Got pretty straight into. Two thoughts. Namely of.
Building houses and growing fruit trees and. Reafforestation. Now. At that level. Ton of boys worked brilliantly.
There's a huge number of. Really beautiful houses. Very laid back into the environment. Very. Non-intrusive.
A lot of really good fruit trees and other trees. There throughout the whole property they regressed.
Down in the valley. Has been really beautiful and the. Why the. There are so many trees and.
The orchards have broken up. Has really minimized. Insect problems. But then.
Be you know on those two aspects of the whole tree. Agricultural. And the housing.
The whole other levels of mechanical. Economics and post mechanical economics. Have. I have.
I'm leaving at early stage. And there's being i.
A really strong argument against them being dealt with at a community level.
In the early days of town of a force there was a strong desire. A lot of people. To limit. Tolerable for was.
And its activities. To housing and tree. Goblins and.
That sort of kept on and i've ever written throughout the whole valley this lodge fear of development which. Amongst.
Not everyone. Maybe not amongst the majority. But certainly amongst a very strong.
Number of people and they feel it very strongly and i try to put a whole inference of badness. Against any.
Economic activity that is not. At their sky. And that ends up with a real real difficulty a real. A hard press.
I suppose you could say it just puts anyone who's trying to. Do things that are not.
Has building or a tree god nor in titan. That i major disadvantage.
Where they have to carry a lot of extra trouble a lot of extra white in order to do the same job which. Yes it's it's.
One of the one of the aspects of why this is it's been difficult to get a community level playing on on economics.
Beyond the house and gardens. As being. Part of the origins of the festival itself.
And in the same many people coming up. And being part of the festival. Who had i vietnam protest. Our entire nation.
Before they came. And when you're dealing with protests vietnam classic example.
The key thing that you're always centering on. Is saying no. You are constantly.
Coming up with a million brilliant arguments. And a million. Brilliant. Why is all.
The saying no trying to stop things. And in fact of course. When the terrain year.
Issue blew up up here to that end of a tad completely. Into the ecological question. Of saying no.
And concentrating on stopping things. Of learning how to stop things. Of spending.
Investing your life safe it in learning how to say no and to stop things. As i model. Good. Not only.
Learning it as a skill. But actually investing it with. That is the moral good thing. And anyone who is not doing.
Learning and specializing in having to say no is doing something bad. And that.
That's being there in russia right now for a huge amount of the years we. We had a lot of debates. In niman.
Where graham dunstan. And some other people were trying to argue that. We had to keep the whole of the valley.
Only working on spontaneous structures. And i argued the case that it had to be on.
Ongoing structures that had the capacity for spontaneity. As distinct from. Demanding that the.
Structures be spontaneous structures. The reality is that.
For structures that are going to say no that are going to oppose things. You only need a spontaneous structure.
However grand dunstan's now come back to town wanting to do a twenty year festival next year.
And he's really frustrated that there's no. Ongoing structure. It's capable of helping him do that it's. It's the.
It just runs with the philosophy that if people. Practice at saying no too often.
They in fact find it difficult to understand how difficult it is to get new things occurring. To write a play.
To put on a play to do a musical. To start a business. To do a musical is to start a business. You can't.
The number of people that you're going to involve the amount of time that you're going to ask of them.
The amount of extra. Materials and resources that you're going to need. It is equal to a small business.
And i suppose i've always had some level of our entire nation.
Of that i've had difficulty getting something that does not exist. To actually exist. So. That's the challenge.
Stop is right. Next. Role race. Beyond. Beyond their houses and three gardens. Getting other things to occur.
Requires a an orientation.
That means that they have to actually get themself and other people to agree on how to do things together. All.
Business or. Things that require. Twenty thirty people tend to work together. Involve. Business transactions.
Whether it's running a preschool or whatever. You have to get and then. People agreeing. Saying yes.
To putting in a lot of effort. In order to get a whole range of things coordinated together.
And that our intention is i suppose. Something that. Has taken a fair wall in him and.
We early on a timetable for was gave up the idea of trying to get a lot of houses built by building in it for instance.
That's one of the possibilities we could have looked at. But it.
We weren't going to be have to agree on many of the details.
And so it was going to be a lot easier for people to go out and build their own houses.
And in fact that has had the major advantage of their being an incredibly low mortgage debt level.
But it also has meant that. That. Part of the of the economy. Of past building. That has not existed.
And if you look at a stride in. National statistics you see that the building industry the home building industry.
Is a large percentage of the of a whole economy. Well in nimbin that part of the economy.
Has only been one quarter of the size for this father per head of population and it's only been a quarter of the size.
Because of people. Building their own. That means that the whole whether. Economics of the area. Are also slowed down.
And it also means that all of those people that would normally have experience in doing business. Building houses.
Have not had that experience. So it's really.
I still think the easiest way for newman in the future would be to take it on consciously and i met. Learning how.
To create businesses consciously. And i mean. In a fairly open.
Information system where people throughout the whole community can know what the business is doing in economic terms.
And how. And seeing the actual business is growing. You know overall turnover.
And seeing how much more they're producing. So that then the whole community.
Could have a sense of a level of economic growth and could actually have its own figures and to cystic so.
I think it comes down to a question where you remain poor. If you think your poor.
And if you start to decide that you're not really very poor. And you can actually justify what you're doing.
Then you can change your. Economic status from poor. To. Well off. Simply from a change of attitude.
You talk about these things and you know writing. This is that. Yeah but you know when it when it's close.
Now i don't think it should make itself out of the system.
But i think it should stop pretending that the system doesn't exist. Except when it wants something off. I mean.
The fact that new guinea exists. Or indonesia exists.
If you recognise it exists it doesn't mean that you have to be part of it.
But you do have to recognise its legitimacy in its own place. And you have to be able to compare yourself against it.
And likewise newman. Could have its own currency. But that currency would have to be real. Against this.
You can have it's own economy. But that economy has to be real. Against the australian economy.
And i just read the other day that decca. In bangladesh has won six sixteen percent. One six. Of its total economic.
Work. Is on rickshaws. And i don't call them rituals. But they're the whole the whole wheeling. Of people.
By human effort. On the back of. Two wheeled cots. Is one sixth of the total workforce. Of doctors job.
Either in building them repairing them or doing the wheeling. Now that's. Economically real inside dhaka.
But it's not a very wise use of life. And likewise in him and. The question. You don't have to be.
Be part of the system.
You know order to realise that economics does actually exist and even if no one talks about it then.
Every day of the week a certain number of people are going to be building some houses.
And some other people are going to be doing this and some people are going to be doing that.
Main event to go to a limited number of people in any one valley.
And they are only going to do a certain amount of work. Each week. And some will do more and that.
That america can lift and drop. Depending on how they feel.
But as soon as you start talking about what people are doing and where the people. Getting themselves.
Poorer or richer. Then you're talking about economics. He's probably right. He's lost. I think it means. Well.
All things. Do. Night. Time and then.
Like this there's not a lot of ways in which i see now except if you look at include one xtra factor in there.
Of whether they feel that they are poor or. Well off.
When you look at at time before was that some really interesting examples and comparisons that you can make.
And one of the factors a value that i think you have to take into it is. Is i person free to move.
It's all very well to have a beautiful house and. Lots of really beautiful things about the place.
That's the environment. It's spectacular. And the life star can be very enjoyable.
If you think you got the right to leave. Even heaven. Can be a terrible place if you feel trapped there. Now.
With tangible. There is. Because of the head space. There is i. Poverty. A poverty. That holds.
People in there when they may not want to be there. The comparison is really easy.
And with another place in the district court bill includes. Which was started ten years after kind of a force.
It just had its tenth year anniversary a few weeks ago. And that bill includes which is the second biggest. Community.
Around here after town of all force. People who joined it. Ten years ago the first people. Paid for the.
And dollars for a share. And i think it runs from four up to about i. Nine thousand people now.
The minimum amount that. If they wish to leave their empty block of land. Is now worth twenty two thousand dollars.
Empty. And that's the minimum. So they're. For the for what they've put in.
And i don't feel trapped in in the sense that they have to stay there because they can't afford to go anywhere else.
Whereas at the same time. I know of one situation. A friend of mine. Where he if he sold his house and land.
A town of will force. He would only be getting something in the twenty's. With a house as well.
There's no in fact that the house of his house that town of always family beautiful. Then. Lots of thing.
Places a bill in place. But because of the structure. And the head spice. Town of all fours thinks it's paul.
And therefore. People who are thinking of coming in are only willing to pay. Small amounts of money.
Now that means that someone who is there a ton of will. It's not actually worth their while to sell.
Because for whatever good. They won't be i've got a very far in terms of any other house. If i sell out. B.
I have to use the money just for. Living in the period of time before they have anything else.
That means of us and isn't free to move. Now what's the whole lesson.
That's been going on out of the east europe and russia. But the people felt that they weren't free to move. And now.
If they try to move.
They're not free to move either because germany and france
and all those countries know how many people would like to move at least for economic reasons.
And they don't want that many slaves coming into western europe.
But the sense of being not freedom of is not just a question of physical restrictions.
It's also largely an economic question. If you're you know. Not having them. Yes. And. Not having learnt. You know.
Yeah yeah i realize what you. I suppose part of that. Poverty headspace.
Is a whole suggestion that money is inherently evil that. Wiring about it or. Making it or getting it.